[Music]
today the Pope made his last public
appearance yeah that is until the new
season of Dancing with the Stars he's
paired up with Karina oh I don't know
who that is
neither do I writers told me to say it
no this is true Pope Benedict has
revealed that after he steps down he
will destroy his papal ring that's what
he said yeah
in keeping with Vatican law he will
destroy the ring by casting it back into
the fires of Mordor
[Applause]
I bet the the Pope said that the past
few years have been very difficult for
the church and at times he felt that
quote the Lord seemed to sleep that's
what he said
when asked for comment the Lord said you
try staying awake through a Latin Mass
those things will kill you so you know
the Pope should know better then right
before you retired to criticize the boss
saying that God seemed to sleep
Oh God was the boss yeah exactly yeah I
mean come on yeah imagine a guy
criticizing his boss
yeah that's all you do 24/7 is tell me
how I could be better
for this hour I don't
leave me alone now yeah yeah yeah on
your own big international controversy
about the Oscars did you hear about this
when they aired the Oscars in Iran the
Iranian government digitally added
sleeves to Michelle Obama's gown yeah
they also altered the video so that
Jennifer Lawrence is now deliberately
tripped by the Israelis the producers of
Downton Abbey the PBS show Downton Abbey
have revealed that the show will have
its first black character yeah B story
yeah next season Lord Grantham will
receive a special visit from Sir
mix-a-lot
crazy story senior citizens are now
catching STDs at a record rate
[Applause]
the help is that they're delighted by
that story
grandma's getting gonorrhea
[Applause]
that sounds like a song from the 1920s
old crime boss getting gonorrhea don't
dance to it
what dance was that what the hell is now
that's what old beautiful
oh don't don't that's right senior
citizens are now catching STDs at a
record rate yeah that's uh yeah so what
so now old guys are getting up in the
middle of the night to scream while they
pee it seems like you like the setup
more than the joke itself got it
hundreds of employees of Weight Watchers
are complaining about the company's low
wages yeah
the employee said they're paying us
peanuts which by the way are only six
points of serving I'm winning you back
slowly a South Carolina Court on
Wednesday ruled that James Brown's
estate is not being divided up the way
he wants it or want it yeah
unfortunately it's hard to tell because
all his will states is divided up
divided on up
divide up divide on up I'm working hard
out here you're earning it tonight I'm
earning it yeah
I'm earning it joke 5co that's the way
we old-timers do it check this out a 114
year old woman in Japan is now
officially the world's oldest woman yeah
this was exciting news for the world's
second oldest woman Steven Tyler
[Applause]